La altura de un triángulo es
4cm menos que el largo de su base.
Si el área del triángulo
es de 30 cm cuadrados,
encuentra la base
y la altura del triángulo.
Usa la fórmula área
es igual a 1/2 de base por altura
para encontrar el área del triángulo.
Y bien
¿Cómo resolvemos este problema?
Lo primero que voy a hacer aquí
es dibujar un triángulo,
para que veamos cuánto debe de valer su base
y cuánto debe de valer su altura.
Voy a suponer que su base vale "b",
esto es lo que vale la longitud de su base,
mientras que su altura va a valer "h",
la longitud de su altura es "h",
y yo sé que para sacar
el área de un triángulo,
necesito la fórmula
área es igual a 1/2 de base por altura,
hasta aquí todo lo hemos visto,
pero quiero que chequen
el primer renglón de este problema,
que dice, la altura de un triángulo
es 4 centímetros menos que la longitud de su base,
es decir como la longitud de su base vale "b"
entonces la altura es lo mismo que "b" menos 4,
y entonces ya puedo yo plantear mi ecuación cuadrática. Fíjense bien
30 que es el área
que nos dice que tiene el triángulo,
30 centímetros cuadrados
es igual a 1/2 de la base,
1/2 por la base por la altura
pero la altura en este caso
es igual a "b" menos 4,
por lo tanto en lugar de altura voy a sustituir
el valor de la altura que es "b"menos 4
y entonces ahora si,
ya tengo una ecuación que resolver para "b"
y perfecto, porque ya tenemos la ecuación de este problema
y es que muchas veces
esto es lo más difícil de resolver un problema,
¿y entonces qué queda?
30 es igual a 1/2 por "b" por "b" menos 4
y déjame de escribirlo mejor así,
así se va a ver mucho más claro, primero voy a multiplicar el 1/2 por "b" y me va a quedar "b" medios
que multiplica a "b" menos 4,
y ahora voy a distribuir el "b" medios
por cada uno
de los 2 términos de este binomio,
y me queda "b" cuadrada entre 4...
no, no, no, no, esperen
entre 2,
hay que tener mucho cuidado
y después me va a quedar
-4 entre 2 es 2,
entonces me queda -2b
y a continuación
para que no me quede este término
de "b" cuadrada entre 2
y no me queden fracciones,
lo que voy a hacer
es multiplicar todo por 2,
esta parte por 2,
y esta parte por 2
2 por 30 y 60 es igual a 2 por "b" cuadrada entre 2,
esto es "b" cuadrada y 2 por dos son 4
entonces me queda -4b
y bueno recuerden que les he contado que lo mejor
es ver las ecuaciones cuadráticas
igualadas a 0,
por lo tanto, lo que voy a hacer es restar
de ambos lados de la ecuación 60
para que me quede una ecuación cuadrática
igualada a 0,
lo que tenemos que saber es el valor de "b"
de esta ecuación,
por lo tanto -60 de un lado
y -60 del otro,
60 y 60 se van,
y me queda
"b" cuadrada menos 4b - 60
y ahora sí, esto es igual a 0
y es justo lo que yo quería
y a esta ecuación cuadrática
la quiero resolver
por el método de factorización
es decir,
tras lo que voy,
es factorizar esta expresión que tengo aquí,
en 2 binomios tales que
al multiplicarse
me den igual a 0,
lo que quiere decir que
o el primer binomio es 0
ó el segundo binomio es 0,
lo cual me va a ayudar a resolver esta ecuación,
pero bueno
para factorizar de esa expresión,
voy a buscar 2 números que al sumarse me den -4
y al multiplicarse me den -60,
así que vamos a anotarlo
"a" más "b" me tienen que dar -4
y "a" por "b" me tiene que dar -60
2 números que sumados me den -4
y que multiplicados me den -60
y ya con esto
se ve mucho más claro que es lo que quiero,
entonces ahora si,
lo primero que quiero que veamos,
es que "a" por "b" tiene que ser -60
por lo tanto,
uno de los dos números tiene que ser positivo
y el otro tiene que ser negativo,
el 60 lo puede descomponer en 1 y 60
pero están muy lejos estos dos números,
pues si buscamos su diferencia es 59
y eso está muy lejos del -4.
Otra descomposición es 2 y 30 pero su diferencia es 28 y también sigue muy lejos,
3 y 20 pero
20 menos3 es 17,
todavía seguimos muy lejos,
son números muy muy lejanos,
a ver vamos a ver 4 y 15,
4 y 15 la diferencia es 15 menos 4 que es 11
también seguimos muy lejos,
a ver 5 y 12,
5 y 12, 5 por 12 es 60
pero 12 menos 5 es 7
ya nos vamos acercando...
A ver vamos a ver 6, 6 que multiplica a 10 es 60
y 10 menos 6 es 4.
¡Perfecto!
Ya tengo aquí que es 6 y 10,
solamente que como mi resultado tiene que ser - 4
el negativo para que gane
tiene que ser el 10,
entonces me va a quedar el
6 y -10, y entonces
esto ya me da pie a que yo pueda escribir
esta ecuación de la siguiente manera.
"b" más 6 que multiplica
a "b" menos 10
y ya estoy factorizando
esta ecuación cuadrática,
que yo tenía aquí arriba,
y ahora si,
ya tengo 2 binomios
que están multiplicando,
y que son igual a 0,
y bueno, hay que tener mucho cuidado
porque esta "b" no es lo mismo que esta "b".
Esta "b" significa la longitud de mi base
y esta "b" lo puse
para poner los números que buscábamos.
Es más no me gustaría que nos confundiéramos,
buscábamos 2 números que su suma tenía que ser igual a -4
y que su multiplicación
tuviera que ser -60
y no tiene nada que ver
con la base de mi triángulo,
así que mejor lo voy a poner
como "x" y "y",
"x" más "y" es igual a -4
y "x" por "y" es igual a -60
pero en fin, también otra cosa que les quería comentar,
es que esta misma factorización
pudimos obtenerla por agrupación,
sin embargo ya que la obtenemos
¿Ahora qué vamos a hacer?
Tenemos dos binomios
que multiplicados nos dan 0
y dos cosas
multiplicadas nos dan 0,
si la primera es 0,
ó en su dado caso la segunda es 0.
Si la primera fuera 0,
entonces me quedaría que "b" más 6 es igual a 0
y si la segunda fuera 0,
me quedaría que "b" menos 10 es igual a 0
y bueno, ya de aquí puedo resolver para "b",
me va a quedar que "b" es igual a -6
ó en su dado caso,
si yo paso el 10 del otro lado,
me va a quedar que "b" es igual a 10,
pero positivo
y ya que tengo mis 2 raíces
o mis 2 soluciones de esta ecuación.
Tanto "b" igual a -6
como "b" igual a 10
solucionan esta ecuación cuadrática
que yo tenía aquí,
y ya llegué al resultado,
no, hay que tener cuidado porque
también es muy importante revisar
que mi solución sea congruente,
con lo que se está planteando en el problema.
Pero antes que eso
déjame ponerlo también aquí por agrupación,
para que veas que llegamos al mismo resultado.
Me queda 0 es igual a
"b" cuadrada más 6b
que era uno de los dos números
que habíamos encontrado,
-10b el cual era el otro número
-60
y entonces voy a factorizar
los primeros 2 términos de esta ecuación,
y le voy a sacar factor común,
el factor común
es "b" que multiplica "b" más 6
y en mis otros dos términos
también le voy a sacar factor común,
y el factor común es -10
que multiplica "b" más 6
y aquí, si te das cuenta
tengo "b" más 6 y "b" más 6
"b" más 6  por lo tanto es un factor común
de esta expresión que tengo aquí,
por lo tanto me va a quedar
"b" menos 10
que multiplica a "b" más 6
porque "b" más 6  era factor común,
y los otros 2 términos
eran "b" y -10,
y si te das cuenta
llegamos a lo mismo.
Aquí está mi factor común
y me queda "b" menos 10
que multiplica a "b" más 6,
que era justo
lo que teníamos aquí abajo,
solamente que aquí abajo
lo hicimos en un solo paso,
es lo mismo,
tú puedes utilizar el método que más te sirva
o en el cual te acomodes mejor
y bueno, ya que tengo mis
dos posibles resultados de "b"
quiero ver
cuál es congruente con el problema,
porque date cuenta
si "b" valiera -6
entonces esto no tendrá sentido
porque tendríamos un lado negativo,
y no conozco ningún triángulo
con lados negativos,
no podemos tener longitudes negativas
y si "b" vale 10,
entonces sí nos queda de resultado,
por lo tanto esto lo voy a tachar,
este no me sirve por que no tenemos lados negativos,
y me quedo con que
"b" es igual a 10
y si "b" vale 10
eso quiere decir que la base vale 10,
y entonces la altura vale 10 menos 4 lo cual es 6.
Ya tengo que la altura vale 6,
la base vale 10
y sería bueno rectificar si realmente
estamos haciendo el procedimiento correcto.
Me quedaría
10 por 6 me da 60,
60 entre 2 son 30 centímetros cuadrados
y perfecto,
logramos resolver este problema.